I think an insatiable curiosity is a
quality that comments at every scientist
especially the ones were successful
if you're trying to look for interested
in projects interesting questions the
more fundamental better more interesting
it is the broader the implications dr.
Shaw sex work is on the development of
artificial cells so he's working at the
cusp of chemical and biological
evolution so it's really neat to talk to
somebody like that
Jack Shostak is a biologist his
prize-winning work was on telomeres
which are caps on DNA that explained a
lot of things about how the translation
of DNA works and his current research
interests are in the origins of life
once life gets started it can adapt and
evolve and colonize many many different
environments our astronomer friends
discovered already over 400 earth-like
planets and the question of whether
there might be life out there and those
other worlds really boils down to the
question of whether it's easy or hard to
make that transition from the chemistry
of an early planet to the beginnings of
biology your research you know from
hearing you speak yesterday is very much
curiosity driven and low real practical
application I can perceive so as a young
scientist it seems like there's a big
shift away from that most of the funding
most of research is it's industrially
driven or its applications based and it
seems like I mean a really fundamental
change in the way we think about science
and the way a scientist career is going
to be shaped do you think it's that
changes is drastic you know it's a
little hard to find the balance and it
shifts back and forth I think right now
there's maybe a little too much emphasis
on the translational work for my for my
preference I mean for example in the
work I do that you know that led to the
prize it was basic very basic research
at the time we were just curious about
some DNA mechanisms had no idea about
importance in biology or medicine and
you know over the years these things
just sort of emerged if that kind of
basic research isn't supported and
eventually the pipeline will run dry sir
pertaining to the origins of
biomolecular hungry reality this is a we
were talking about the issue of the
kinds of molecules that came together to
make the first living cells and in
particular the fact that a lot of these
molecules come in two forms that are
mirror images of each other but in
modern biology we we generally see only
one of those mirror image forms so
there's been a long-standing question as
to how how that got started how on the
early Earth did we end up with with
having only one of the two possible
mirror images for the for the
fundamental building blocks of the first
cells chirality comes from the greek
word for handedness and and that that
actually provides us with a ready
analogy because to be non-superimposable
on your mirror image you can see that
your hands are mirror images of one
another but when you superimpose them
your thumb stick out on either side so
they're non-superimposable on their
mirror image and molecules at a
microscopic scale have the same property
in three dimensions
biomolecular Homo chirality is a fancy
term for pretty simple ideas so amino
acids and sugars which are the building
blocks of life are all almost completely
when they're found on threshold earth
one hand and there's not any real
explanation for why this is so
20 years ago it just looked so
impossible because I mean there were
almost no mechanisms that we're well
known and now we have so many different
ways in which the problem could be
solved that it's it's almost
embarrassing so since you've worked so
much on chiral catalysts have you
thought about ways in which there could
be chiral auto catalysis and prebiotic
chemistry um so the examples that are
out there really don't explain it that's
for sure so I mean a dialkyl zinc
reaction that's not a happen under where
do I have conditions sir that that's not
it seems worth trying to think of yeah
reactions that could be there's some
other interesting things than that I
guess our way outside both our fields
about you know what established that
Kairo bias in the first place so there's
some there's some really interesting
stuff about using just physical forces
to to impose chirality and so oh you
mean like magnetic yeah our circularly
polarized light is red well that's the
usual explanation for the
extra-terrestrial stuff the meteorite
stuff right the merchants in meteorite
provides significant evidence that the
origins of biomolecular home will
chirality could be extraterrestrial it
landed in Australia and 69 and it had a
number of what we would call
non-terrestrial amino acids they are
very very similar in structure but just
had one small structural change from the
building blocks that compose our bodies
and you know everything else that all
other living things and they exhibited a
small enantiomeric excess so instead of
a 50-50 mix of right and left hands they
had a small excessive one over the other
and that excess favored the chiral sense
that we see in the terrestrial amino
acids that compose living things on
earth so the amino acids that were on
the merchants and meteorite that
exhibited this small enantiomeric excess
and they were all alpha methyl amino
acids and all of this that's what last
exactly right so if that was the source
of our initial Cairo bias that means
that there would not only have to be a
mechanism for amplification but first
the mechanism for a reaction of that non
terrestrial amino acid into the ones
that we see in our bodies otherwise you
know we would have alpha methyl amino
acids I'm in living or not sure I buy
that and you could have something that
makes normal amino acids chiral of
course it wouldn't that wouldn't last
for four billion years but doesn't have
to it just has to last long enough to
come and have an influence in the right
environment on the early Earth well yeah
it would have had to have happened on
earth I mean I do really think something
could make it through the atmosphere as
a rasa rasa my zabal stereocenter within
well when the merchants of meteorite
fell to the ground I remember the
stories right it's still cold in the
middle right and I mean you got this
skin formed around the outside of
something that's conserved in there yeah
a few of his opinion surprised me
there's some theories that the chiral
bias of amino acids came from some
extraterrestrial origin and the nature
in which they were delivered and so the
form the molecular form I've always
thought could only be a non rasa my
zabal alpha methyl amino acid which is
just a bunch of jargon but he he
actually had some other opinions about
that that the temperature of the inside
of a meteorite to delivering these type
of molecules would set cold enough that
that wouldn't be a problem your
prize-winning work on telomeres that
work is a phenomenon that applies to all
different forms of life I just wonder if
that's sort of I don't even know if this
is a word but fundamentally get it draws
you in your work is that something that
you you feel like absolutely okay I mean
I think if you're trying to look for
interesting projects interesting
questions the more fundamental better
right the more interesting it is the
broader the implications and so thinking
about the origin of life fits perfectly
into that it's not much this more
fundamental right I like thinking of our
work and a bigger perspective and when I
say our work I mean like just
generally is like you know the
scientific community and it's a very
palatable idea to have have you know the
kind of like aesthetically pleasing
things that we see in culture and the
things around us b/c those same things
manifested in science so so right let's
it's one of the things that drives me
crazy is when people criticize science
for taking away the perspective of
natural beauty but you know just as we
you know we look around and it's
everything we see here is is so
beautiful when you look at the
structures of molecules as we could
appreciate their very beautiful
so I think if you know more about
science you can appreciate beauty in
different places and it's there's
there's always surprises you always see
new things and they're wonderful yeah so
yeah I think of science as the substance
of aesthetics it's like us a like the
thing that was a fantastic experience it
was I don't have a little bit speechless
I'm very excited I already feel like I
have a fresh perspective day-to-day
bench work gets really tedious and I I
just feel really excited about what I do
again and not that I ever really lost it
but you know a renewed bigger even
though we're doing very different kinds
of experiments in our labs because our
interest do you have this this area of
overlap we had a great conversation it
was very fun talking to Abigail about
all of these ideas she's thought broadly
about fundamental things like the origin
of life
you